[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
So nice to see you all.
Hope everybody is
having a great week.
I'm Rachael Dempsey, I lead our
Pro Community here at Posit.
The Data Science
Hangout is our space
to chat about data
science leadership,
questions you're facing,
getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of
data across all different
industries.
And so if this is your
first time joining us here
today, it happens every
Thursday at the same time
in the same place.
So we'd would love to have you
come back and join us again.
Also, if you're
watching on YouTube
and you want to join
us live some day,
there will be a link in the
recording details for you
to add it to your calendar, too.
At the Hangout, we're
all dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
And so we love when
we can hear questions
from everyone no matter
your level of experience
or area of work.
And it is totally OK to
just listen in if you want.
You don't have to
jump in, but if to and
you want to ask questions or
provide your own perspective,
there's three ways
that you can do that.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And just put a little
star next to it
if you want to me
to read it instead.
And then we also
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously, too,
and I totally forgot
to make that today,
so I will make that
as we get started here
and share it in the
chat in just a second.
But I'm so excited.
We have two featured leaders
here joining us today.
Amanda Ahrens is ESG
Data Architect at Dow,
and Alix Schmidt, a
Chemical Engineer and Data
Scientist at Dow as well.
And I'd love to have
you both maybe kick
things off by introducing
yourself and sharing
a little bit about your
role and also something
you like to do outside of work.
Amanda, do you want to go first?
Hi, I'm Amanda Ahrens.
My job is an enterprise
architecture.
So like the title says, I
focus on environmental, social,
and governance
data architecture.
So really, all things
sustainability,
climate, circularity, say,
for materials for Dow.
And it's been really exciting.
I wanted to take the role
because as a data scientist,
I was frustrated that
I didn't necessarily
have data access in
a streamlined way,
and so deployment of
models was challenging.
And so I wanted to be
part of that solution
and I've always
wanted to get more
into the sustainability realm,
so it a good opportunity.
I really enjoy curling
outside of work.
So even though I moved to Texas,
I still keep up on curling
and get to find others from
Canada and the Midwest that
transplanted to Texas there.
That's great.
Thanks for joining us, Amanda.
I think that might be the first
time for curling has been one,
but maybe not.
Maybe in the chat
we'll see some others.
Alix, you want to
introduce yourself?
Yeah.
My name is Alix Schmidt.
I am originally a chemical
engineer, as Rachael said.
Got into data science with a
master's degree kind of halfway
through my career at this point.
So I've worked
mostly in R&amp;D at Dow.
So making new
products, understanding
materials, a little
bit in manufacturing
where we can use our operations
data to troubleshoot problems.
Right now, I am in
Dow's central R&amp;D
group for real deep technical
expertise in information
research.
So that's our department that
does research and innovation
for computing technologies
and related digital tools.
And I'm really mostly working on
our ML ops and model deployment
strategy.
So, of course, there's a
technical aspect to that,
but a lot of what
I work on is really
around change management,
upskilling of data scientists
so that they can follow
our governance standards,
getting team leaders and
project sponsors educated
so we are all on the
same page about what
it takes to deploy a model.
So that's not something I
ever expected to be doing,
but it's fun and I get
to work with a whole lot
of different people
all the time.
So yeah, and who knows
what will be the next step.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I love it.
ALIX SCHMIDT: I also--
yes. And outside
of work, I
am a potter.
So I do pottery.
And I say that because
I'll be drinking coffee,
but I only use handmade mugs
now to support local artists.
So this is a local artist
in Midland, Michigan named
Anna [? Safransky. ?] So yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
That's beautiful.
So thank you both
for joining us today.
Something I have been really
excited to ask you all about
is about the
community-building that you all
have done at Dow and about data
competitions and conferences.
And I just posted on
LinkedIn earlier this week
that a lot of
people have recently
been asking me about
how to get started
with their own internal
data conference.
And I've been
asking for some tips
that I've learned from
others because I've never
done that myself.
So I would love to just be able
to hear a little bit about some
of the events that
you lead, too.
Amanda, maybe you can
kick off with the background
of the community and the
journey that we've been on?
AMANDA AHRENS: Yeah,
that sounds good.
So we have an internal
data science community
that really has allowed us to
lay the foundation for ever
even being able to approach
a data science conference.
And we did successfully have
a full data science conference
last year.
So we call it the Insight
Scientist Community
and it was established in 2015.
And I had the
privilege of helping
to launch it as one of the
managers for the community
at that point in time.
And since then, it has grown
to over 500 members inside Dow.
And of those, about
100 of those people
are full-time practitioners,
and the remaining
are interested parties, citizen
data scientists, people getting
into data science, learning.
And we have a good breakdown
a big chunk, about 35%
from R&amp;D. We have another
third from operations.
And then a good chunk as well
from IT and supply chain,
and then the rest is scattered
across the other functions
and businesses
within the company.
So throughout the years,
we've been able to do--
we started off smaller
with poster sessions.
We've kept up these
monthly technical meetings
where people can showcase--
just showcase what
they've been working on.
So it's a more constant
feed of information
out to the community.
But then we were able to
do our first data science
challenge in 2017.
And then we did
another one in 2019,
and then we did our last one as
part of the full Data Science
Conference in 2022.
So it's been quite
a journey so far.
So that's a little
bit of background
on the foundation
for how we were
able to get this all together.
I'm not as used to
having two leaders on here,
so feel free to
just jump in when
you want if you have
something else to add, too,
but I will also direct the
questions to both of you,
so whoever feels like answering.
But I remember when
we were talking
a little bit about
the competition,
you mentioned that you had some
executives who are part of that
as well, and they were helping
judge some of the submissions.
And I was just
curious, how did you
go about bringing this community
up to the executive level
as well and do you have any
tips for all of us to do that?
Yeah, so-- go ahead, Alix.
Yeah.
We are very lucky
that we've had really
strong executive sponsorship
even from the beginning.
So when Amanda was there at
the founding of the community,
I think we-- or the
sponsor, the manager
that really said yes, I'm
going to put my people's
time into starting to do this,
I think reported directly
to our CIO or maybe two levels.
So it was a very
close connection
to executive leadership
even from the beginning.
And it was actually that
executive leader, our CIO,
Melanie Kalmar, who I think
proposed the first event that
ended up being the
data science challenge.
So we had had many events.
We did poster sessions, we
did seminars, career seminars
as well for our members, but
this was the first thing that
was really like--
I think the executive
leaders said,
how can we use this community
to start creating value
for the company?
I think-- I've got to believe
that's what originally
came to their minds.
And so they suggested, why
don't you go figure out
how to do a hackathon?
And that word can mean a lot
of things to a lot of people.
But after really
talking about it,
we settled on this
sort of Shark Tank--
like the TV show Shark Tank
style thing where groups
come up with a project
idea and pitch it
to this executive panel.
So I don't know if, Amanda,
you were involved in--
at a step from getting that
executive sponsor, the one,
to getting a panel
of eight executives
in the first challenge?
Not so much the first
one, but in other areas,
I feel like what
really works is having
the executive that's already
on board sell it to the rest.
Like, it doesn't work so much
if you're out there by yourself.
If you can go along with
that executive that's already
on board and explain
the vision of why
you want to do a Data Science
Challenge or a Data Science
Conference and what's
in it for them,
it was pretty easy to
get them to say yes,
because they felt like
it was an opportunity
that the other
executive was giving
them to really help
set data science
direction for the company.
Because, I mean, in all three
Data Science Challenges,
winning projects were
implemented and in some way.
Even if they weren't
funded directly initially,
there was such high
interest by the executives
in moving forward with the idea.
ALIX SCHMIDT: Yeah.
All right. The
number one project
from last year
actually just won
an Edison Award,
which is a really big research
and development in STEM award.
And so that's like an external
recognition, too, of that.
And that project, I mean,
pieces of it were happening,
but one of the things we try
to do with the competition
element of the event is
say, really, a lot of value
is created at the interface
of different functions
and different
organizations in a company
as big as Dow, which is
like 37,000 employees.
And so one of the things
we encourage folks to do
is like network and get
out there and find people
in parts of the company that
you wouldn't normally talk to.
And so that project
actually brought
three very small projects from
our toxicology department,
our molecular discovery research
area, and our supply chain area
together to make a
really powerful tool
for making safer and more
sustainable products.
So I think that one is like such
an awesome example of exactly
the vision of the event and to
get that external recognition
was really cool.
That's amazing.
It's really cool to hear how
you brought together people
from all different parts
of the organization,
too, who maybe would have
never worked together.
ALIX SCHMIDT: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think a huge part of being
able to do that is making sure
that you set a theme that
resonates with the executives,
but also, the mid-level
managers because they have
to be supportive
of their employees
actually participating in
the Data Science Challenge,
because seeing how ours
was Shark Tank style,
it wasn't just a day
or two days or whatever
where people were working on a
problem with the same data set.
It was actually over a
longer period of time.
So I think beginning
to end, the challenge
was more around two months.
And so there was a lot
of time spent there,
so people had to feel like it
was worthwhile for their team
to be spending
their time up there.
And so the first theme
was more general.
It was like improving EBITDA.
And then the second theme was
around employee experience
and customer experience,
which was extremely hot--
like top of mind, a
hot topic at that time.
I mean, it still is, but--
And then the last one
that we did in 2022
was all around sustainability.
So it was on climate, especially
decarbonize and grow, water,
and circularity and
safer materials.
And so that really
resonated with everybody.
Everybody at Dow
is trying to prove
that they're
contributing to that,
and that united a lot
of people to come up
with some great ideas
cross-functionally.
Did you come up with those
themes with the executives--
or like the original
executive sponsor?
So actually, it came--
the latest theme
was brought up to me
by one of the
technical principals
that we had at the
company who just thought
it would be a really
uniting theme,
and then we pitched
it to the executives
that we knew are already on
board and going to help us,
and they were like,
yeah, absolutely,
let's go forward with it.
And we thought that
it was the right time.
Dow seeks to be the most
sustainable material science
company in the world, and so
that's a very front and center
theme for the company, not just
the Data Science Challenge.
And so it's pretty easy to
get executives to rally around
that.
it's like they were
already interested in it,
it was already on
their scorecard,
so might as well add this to
help them achieve their goals.
ALIX SCHMIDT: But
finding themes that
are like enterprise-level
for the whole company
is really important, because one
of the things we were thinking
about is like, OK, let's make
sure the theme doesn't exclude
any one that has a certain type
of job that just doesn't touch
that area.
So if we had a theme that was
more cost-effective materials,
R&amp;D could work on
that, Manufacturing
could work that,
probably Supply Chain,
but you might have
people in Commercial
or Finance or Marketing that it
didn't really resonate as much.
So one, we really
wanted to pay attention
to making sure the theme
could be touched by literally
every role in the
company so that we
weren't excluding anyone.
So executive sponsors tend
to have goals at that level,
and so they did suggest
the first couple.
The one that's really just
make more money, less exciting.
So there is an
element that comes
from the technical
people's input on what they
want to work on.
So yeah, I think that
one's just really--
sometimes you just fall
into a magical happy place
where everybody
aligns on what is fun.
A great point.
So I love talking
about community,
but we don't only have
to talk about community
and the competition here, too.
I see, Libby, you had asked a
question a little bit earlier.
Do you want to jump
in here and ask that?
Yeah, it falls in line
with Katherine's question,
too, because Katherine was
asking about that same area
with upskilling for
your tech stock.
So she was asking you
about the curriculum
and how you tackled the
different use cases and stuff
and skill levels
that people have.
And then my question was on the
end of getting leaders and ELT
people on the same page with
understanding what it actually
takes to deploy a model.
Yeah.
So I think the different parts
of Dow have been on a journey
with this, especially
as we start using
more of the cloud-based tools.
We're a Microsoft
Azure company and we're
trying to use those things,
but of course, they're
changing and maturing
the technology every day.
So I think there's been
definitely some journey
on understanding how to
make those things work
and how, especially in Dow,
there's the Microsoft support
page level of answer,
which is just technical,
but then in Dow,
there's the, OK, well,
how do I actually get
access to that thing
and who's the security approver
and all these other things.
So that was pretty
much just a slog.
Like we just had to like--
the first couple projects,
bless those people
because it was very painful.
But they documented very well.
So they documented the
internal work process
of how to make the external
technology work for us.
So that's enterprise view.
My role is really
specifically in R&amp;D.
And in R&amp;D, we have quite
a different situation
because it's research.
And so you have this
research culture,
and if you haven't
worked in research,
it may be hard to
explain, or my explanation
may fall one-dimensional.
But you never know
what's going to happen.
So you charter a project
and it's very difficult
to estimate the
next things that you
need because it could just
totally fail and whatever.
And so that's the way R&amp;D
project reviews and resourcing
is used to.
And then you're working with all
these people from Information
Systems who have project
managers and they have--
we don't use Agile
for everything,
but they're used to this
very formal Scrum scheduling
and you know exactly what
you want to implement,
and then you just have to do the
steps to get to the known end
product and whatever.
And those are just
like opposite things.
So the situation that
we had was R&amp;D managers
sponsoring projects with a
researchy amount of funding,
and then doing the research
part, and yay, that's good.
But then they expected a
deployment out of the end
because that's what
you see when you
hear about AI and
machine learning
deployments in the world.
And so then that
was the same story.
It's like, the first
few projects were just
really painful.
We had to come back to the
sponsors and say, I'm sorry,
this is going to take
like eight months longer
than you thought it
would and it's also
going to take three more
people, like a lot, lot more
than they had expected.
So now that we're on the
other side of that first batch
of really painful
projects, what I am trying
to do is really
capture what we learned
and work with those
people who now understand,
they're the ones who went
through the learning journey
and make sure we
can replicate that.
So it's things like--
literally-- so I'm preparing--
I'm going to be preparing
a mini-course called
Model Deployment 101.
It's just like literally,
what is a piece of software?
Like what is a
software architecture?
How do you know what you need?
And in my case, we have
a very powerful tool
which is using analogies
to chemical manufacturing.
So everybody in R&amp;D knows,
you make a little flask
of your chemical on the
lab, you're like yay,
I got a new product, but
taking it from like this much
on the lab bench to a
10,000-gallon reactor,
that process is called scale-up,
they know that it's hard and it
doesn't work and it requires
all these specific types
of engineer to make it happen.
And so we're trying to say,
this is the exact same.
Just because you've done it in
your development environment
and this model
works really good,
there's still this
whole process to get
from that to a production
software solution.
And you can put up the
architecture diagram
and see, and be like,
look, these are like pipes.
Data has to flow through them.
Would you have a bench chemist
design your data pipes?
Like no, you wouldn't do that.
That's why we have to have
this particular skill set
on the team, and that's
why we have to have this,
and you know.
So that's been the most
powerful thing I've
heard a lot of feedback about.
Just putting the tasks that
a deployment and development
team has to do into the
words of your client.
And so I'm trying to
get that documented,
get that in an easily
digestible form
so we can kind of get
the education out there
for the leaders.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I really
love that analogy, too.
I know, Katherine you had
an original question, which
was tied into that, too.
So I want to make sure that
you jump in with any follow-up
questions, too, but I think
you had another one you just
put in the chat.
KATHERINE GERTON: Yeah,
in terms of developing
these kinds of continuing
education or community
learnings for your company,
are you doing those live
and do you have somewhere
that they live after you've
done them where somebody
can access it, if they get
onboarded later, to really
keep that learning going?
And how are you managing
that curriculum live
versus not live?
Mm-hmm.
I think we're trying
to make most of them
not live just because the
need to educate somebody
is so irregularly timed.
So it's-- every once in
a while, like next week,
we're going to have a
bunch of interns starting,
and that would be a time when I
could do maybe one live session
and get a bunch of
people trained at once.
But for full-time hires,
they join randomly.
And we've tried other things
with just completely different
types of training in the
past where you try maybe
like a quarterly, and
everybody from the last quarter
catches up.
But some of these things are
so fundamental that people
need to hear them like day 1.
Like, OK, the expectation
is that you use Git.
Like please do that.
And so we don't want to
delay people's work or people
doing work in the way
that we would like.
So I think we're
going to go mostly
like self-learning,
asynchronous kind of approach.
As far as a common
location, we have things
like that for our
technical people
to access technical
trainings, but we
don't have something like
that for more organizational
soft skills kind of trainings.
So I'm going have
to think about that.
One of the things that
we've been thinking about
is, how do we facilitate
these conversations
between the technical experts
and the resource holders
where they basically
describe what they need to do
and then they get the
estimate of how much resource
it will take?
And that's really the point
when they need education.
So we'll have to--
I'll have to think about it.
But I wonder if the
technical people that
are on the other side
of that conversation,
if they know exactly where
to go for that, then that
would be the first start.
KATHERINE GERTON: Yeah. There might be
a way where you
could
put the trainings together
into a training flow,
like do one and the other.
ALIX SCHMIDT: Yeah.
KATHERINE GERTON:
The people who have the answers can
answer questions related to training
1 or 2
or something like
that. But I don't know how
you set that up because I'm not
a web page developer.
Yeah.
We'll figure something out.
We're really-- I'm
really focused on--
because there's a very big--
a very large amount of
learning between where
maybe the average person
in the organization is
and where we would need
them to be actively involved
in a digital project.
And so I'm really
focusing on not
trying to get everything
perfect on the first try,
and right now, and just
getting stuff out there,
and then we'll build together
based on feedback from some
of those early adopters.
But it's easier said than done,
especially when you're the one
that the content
is reflecting on.
I see, Alan, you had a
question in the chat, too.
If you want to jump in next.
Yeah, thanks.
Hi.
I think my question is about the
communication and coordination
between enterprise architecture
level and the R&amp;D level,
and how you figure out how--
if EA needs longitudinal
planning about structure
and people and
resources and stuff,
do you end up with
tension between being
nimble at the R&amp;D
level and knowing
that you'll be supported?
Like that someone will help keep
the lights on at the enterprise
level for the
stuff you're doing.
I think that's a little
different from the scaling-up
question, but I'm not sure.
So how would you
figure out how to do
that kind of planning together
where your cadences may not
match and it may be really hard
to anticipate what you're going
to need in one location
versus the other location
year over year?
In people, in architecture,
in tools, all of that stuff.
Any particular ways
that you're successful?
Yeah.
So I swear, we didn't pay
Alan to ask this question.
[LAUGHTER]
The answer to that
is actually Posit.
So in R&amp;D, where Posit products
such as Workbench, Connect,
Package Manager is
actually one of the things
that differentiates R&amp;D
strategy from elsewhere
in the company that's
fully Azure-based
and does development in Azure
because it is so accessible.
So the accessibility allows us
to have much more participation
in data science from
all of our researchers.
And it's expected that 75%--
probably more, maybe
80 or 90% of things
won't ever make
it to production,
and that's totally fine.
And so Posit is
excellent for that.
And then, of course, we
can use Connect to deploy.
And then if something
really scales big enough
and we have some kind
of technical reason
we need to move it to
Azure, then we can.
So we think of it--
well, I think of it
as like an
accessibility pipeline.
We just want things to be
super easy in the beginning.
And then just make
sure that we have
governance in place to
recognize where we've
crossed some kind of
threshold where we do need
improved reliability.
Maybe we actually need to
get an ML engineer involved
to make a hard-end
solution, or we
do need external connectivity.
So it is our policy in
Dow because our Posit
server is on-prem, we don't let
anybody outside of Dow into it.
So if you have an app that you
want to release to a customer,
we have to do
something different.
So it's on me to figure out
those governance thresholds
of when we need to do something
a little less accessible,
but that's how we
approach the agility,
is just making it super
easy to get started.
That's great, thank you.
And you didn't seed
that question to
me, but we're thinking
about exactly the same thing.
How do we keep an amount
of agility at one level
while-- we're figuring
out a whole enterprise
Azure stack now.
So like I'm taking this to my
enterprise architecture folks
to say like, look,
this can work.
Yeah.
I'll just add, too,
from like the rest
of Dow kind of experience.
So Dow has digital
centers which are
responsible for
digital innovation.
There's information
research embedded in R&amp;D,
and there's one for like
a digital marketplace that
are more on the commercial side,
supply chain side, operations
side.
Anyways, I feel
like what's happened
is the original plan
was that there would
be a sister organization
that would partner
to help support longer-term.
And we're still working toward
that and laying the groundwork,
identifying skills needed that
aren't necessary necessarily
in those service
organizations yet,
and so we've been
building that over time.
And then in the meantime,
those digital centers
are also working to support
those really impactful
new applications and
models and whatnot that
have been built so that people
aren't experiencing them
for a short period of time
during a proof of concept
or a pilot and then
them going away.
So I will say we have some
growing pains that we're
working through
still, but certainly
making a lot of progress even
over the last five years.
Great, thank you.
So much of that is really
resonant and remarkable
how similar some
of our thinking is,
but how we still have
lots of problems to solve.
And yeah, it's great to hear
the way that you're coming at it
and go, OK, we're not
completely out in the wild
and what we're thinking
about is great.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
Love it.
Abigail, I see you have
asked a great question
in the chat that's sparking a
lot of conversation there, too.
Do you want to jump in next?
ABIGAL HADDAD: Thanks.
So this is the only thing
we've run into when hiring.
How do you figure out this is a
skill that this position needs
to have coming in
versus this is something
that we can train people up in?
Woo.
That's a hard question.
[LAUGHS] I think the only answer
that I have for that question I
think we really know is at
this point for, I would say,
our materials and
process-related positions--
so in R&amp;D and Manufacturing,
we have found that it is much
easier to hire people with
degrees in that subject
matter--
so typically
chemical engineering.
And then build up the data
science skill from there
rather than hire a
computer scientist
and teach them enough
chemical engineering
to have those really powerful
conversations that you need
to have in data science
just because, I guess,
the engineers already have some
pretty deep background in math
and data.
But yeah, the domain expertise,
it's really important.
So I think that's the only
thing we really for sure,
is we want to start from
the domain expertise
that we'll need for that role
and then add on digital skills
from there.
But I think it really is
different for different parts
of the project team in terms
of the DevOps engineering
and that kind of stuff, is--
or ML engineering.
They need a lot less of
the domain expertise.
So we haven't exactly
figured out, I would say,
the particular the best way to
hire for those positions yet,
other than that since the
tech-- a lot of the technology
and especially the Azure
particular microservices
and all that different stuff
is so new that we do recognize
that there's nobody that's
got 10 years of experience
in Azure Data
Factory, for example.
So that gives you a
little bit of a relief
knowing that everybody is in the
same boat and training people
and upskilling people right now.
AMANDA AHRENS: Yeah,
I think it depends
on the different areas of Dow,
too, that you're looking at.
So like if we--
well, we share resumes across
the data science teams in Dow,
too.
Like our Common
Metrics Statistics
in Ag Group found
somebody that maybe
doesn't have a robust process
chemistry background, then--
and maybe they're fitting for
a group like our Core Advanced
Analytics Team in IT that is
working more on supply chain
and commercial
logistics challenges,
then we can send that
over and be like,
look out for this person,
they have a really robust
background.
So it's like-- it depends.
But I will say,
too, we realize--
I mean, ideally you would have
both the industry experience
and background, as well as
some exposure to data science
or other digital skills.
And so Dow is
investing in programs
that help provide that.
Like Alix already mentioned,
the intern program
with interns starting that
have more of background--
like they're pursuing PhDs
and chemistry or chemical
engineering or
whatever, but then also
they have some experience
in data science,
and so we want to give
them more experience
at data science and those
digital opportunities.
Also, I am helping
to plan a program.
It's called DAISE, Data
Analytics for Science Immersion
Experience, kind of a mouthful.
But it's actually
targeted undergrads
that are studying STEM.
And these are undergrads from
historically Black colleges
and universities mostly.
And we are giving them
exposure to data sciences
as a partnership with
Carnegie Mellon and Accenture.
And so they're going to be at
Carnegie Mellon for a week.
They'll be learning
some of the--
being exposed to some
of the lecture material
for a master's in
science program--
master's and data science
program that they have.
And then they're actually
going to come to Dow
and be able to see a poster
session where they're exposed
to data science
projects at Dow and get
exposed to technical principles
and data science fellows
and hear about their career
paths and that kind of thing.
So we're trying to also
foster the skills that we
need to hire in the
future because we
know it is a
challenge right now,
it's a lot of one or the other.
So how can we create
those opportunities
where somebody would
already come in with both?
I will add one other thing.
You mentioned, Amanda,
it's a really good point
that we're well-connected
within our community enough
that if somebody
gets a resume that
would be a great add to
Dow but not their group,
we know who to send it to.
And I would say that's probably
mostly because of the Insight
Scientist Community.
So the purpose of the
Insight Scientist Community
is like to make sure that we
don't get too isolated in each
of our functions and that we're
sharing learnings because data
science does cross all domains.
And so when we put
together-- just
to tie back to our
starting discussion.
When we put together
the steering
team of that community, which
we really only formalized,
I don't know, maybe four
years ago now, we have--
we make sure to have
one person from each
of the major functions that
represent the community.
And it's usually like somebody
pretty senior, mid-career,
which is senior
for data science.
And that's very intentional.
And so that that's a
place where we can always
go to for that
cross-functional thing.
Like even if I was in
the community but not
well-connected, I would know
I can send it to my R&amp;D person
and they'll circulate
it in that group
and it'll get to
the right place.
So it does end up being a really
nice vehicle for communication
in that way.
Is that a Teams
group or something,
that you're all like in
constant communication on?
Or how is everybody--
Yeah.
I mean, we existed before we
had Microsoft Teams at Dow,
but I think--
I was actually the chair of that
steering team for two years.
I ended at the end
of last year, hooray!
And so we have monthly
meetings just to make sure
we're making progress
on community goals.
So we did have
community-level goals
around providing training or
providing network opportunities
or creating a sense of
belonging, like community.
And so monthly
meetings, and then yeah,
we use now Microsoft
Teams, so chat and document
storage and things like that all
in one place for coordinating.
Yeah, just like
quick things that
come up in between
the monthly meetings.
Something I thought--
maybe I'm misremembering
this, but I
think we talked about you have
these cool like coffee hour
things that your team
does on Fridays where
you get to meet different
people from other teams.
That is that part of the
Data Insights Community?
d have a couple of
different things like that.
So we have technical seminars
for the full Insight Scientist
Community, but then we have--
what we wanted to do
was enable our members
to find any type of close-knit
community they wanted to.
So you are allowed to make a
subchapter of the community
as long as you have enough
interested people to do that.
And so we started
with local chapters.
So we have certain sites.
There's one in
Michigan, one in Texas,
there's one in the Netherlands,
and one in Shanghai.
For where there's sort of a
high concentration of people,
they can have local
stuff, and then they
have basically full autonomy
over what that group does.
So the Midland one, we pretty
much just have happy hours.
Other ones have book clubs
or presentations or things
like that.
So that's one of
the things that we
do to get to know each other,
yeah, more on a personal level.
I know a couple different
groups within the company
have informal
technical chats right,
almost like a peer review
kind of thing to help people
keep in touch with what
others are learning,
but also get to know
each other a little bit.
Yeah.
So we really try to--
we're not like the end all,
be all of community planning.
We try to create a
platform where people
can use our distribution
list if they
want to get a hold
of everyone, they
can create another channel
in the Microsoft Teams
if they want to
make a subchapter.
Yeah, just be a
platform for folks
to create whatever kinds of
groups they need to create.
Thank you.
There was an anonymous
question a little bit
earlier that was, how do
you regain trust and rebuild
reputations after failing
to meet expectations,
whether time and budget?
If you have
experience with this,
and especially when dealing
with a difficult sponsor?
Yeah.
That's a really,
really good question.
I'll say, we definitely
understand exactly what
you're asking.
I'm trying to think
of a case where
it's actually the
person who we've
gotten to come back around.
I don't know, Amanda or James,
if you have anything in mind.
I actually don't know of
a single individual that
maybe has gotten burned by
some of the early learning
processes we were doing and then
we've gotten to come around.
We're maybe not there
yet mostly it's--
organizationally, we do have
such senior leadership that's
saying like, hey, this
stuff is really important,
we have to start
learning how to do it.
So we do have senior leadership
behind us in terms of saying,
OK, look, we have it out
there, this didn't go well,
but we need to try again.
Like we have to try again,
m we don't have a choice.
But usually the try-again
is with somebody different.
Just by coincidence just because
there's a lot of employees.
So yeah, I don't know.
Personally for just me
and how I run my projects,
I just am transparent.
I can just say like,
yeah, that was awful.
Like it was not fun for anybody,
we didn't expect such whatever,
whatever, whatever.
That's the only way.
You can't cover it up, then
they're not going to trust you.
I think, yeah, transparency
and authenticity
is the only way to trust.
Yeah.
I think-- I can't
think of an example
where I regain
somebody's trust, but I
have had learnings from it.
So I explain, because I feel
like typical IT projects,
because I've spent a good chunk
of my career at Dow in IT,
typical IT projects, like the
only definition of success
is delivery of the
product that you were
supposed to go out and deliver.
Whereas like in R&amp;D, that's
not necessarily the case.
It's like, if you kill
a project quickly,
that can still be
seen as a success.
And so I've been trying to
use that kind of analogy
where it's like, hey, this
is-- we are really genuinely
trying to prove a concept here.
So if we execute this
project and find, hey,
this is absolutely
not going to work,
this approach that we
were hoping would work,
that is actually
still a success.
And making sure
that the sponsors
are clear on what that
definition of success
is from the beginning.
Because there are projects that
are like, OK, we've proved it,
this is really more
we're going into a pilot
or going into an
implementation, and we
do expect delivery at the end.
That is the only
definition of success.
So obviously if we
don't achieve that,
then that would be
not good and they
would have problems with that.
So I feel like just
explaining that difference
and where project actually
is, and the, I guess,
realm of definition
of success is.
Thank you both.
I know-- we have about
10 minutes left here,
so I want to make
sure that I don't
miss any questions that maybe
we're earlier in the chat, too.
So feel free to raise your
hand here on Zoom if you
have other questions, too.
But something I wanted
to ask you both is,
if you were to start
this process of training
and onboarding new data
scientists over again,
is there anything that
you would do differently?
Like having the experience
that you have now.
I don't know that there is.
I think-- it's really
hard to separate
what our specific
people have done
and what a data scientist job
looks like now versus five
years ago from how the industry
as a whole has changed.
Like if I knew we were going to
be here five years ago, I could
have said, oh
yeah, we would have
done a lot more software
development, best practice
training, and coding skills,
and some of that other stuff.
But it's not like--
I don't know, I just think
just things have changed.
And so we will change
and I just can't
imagine what I would
have done knowing
what the future would hold.
Yeah.
That's a non-answer--
ALIX SCHMIDT: --for you.
Yeah, I can't think of
anything in particular.
I will say, I like listening to
the new people's perspectives
because--
well, since I've been at Dow
for almost eight years now,
there's been pretty
drastic improvement.
I'm not saying we
figured everything out,
we don't have a long
way to go still.
We do have a long
But I feel like sometimes
I'm more rosy about some
of the progress, whereas
like somebody new could
be like extremely frustrated.
Like, why can't I do this?
Why am I having these access
issues and that kind of thing.
So it's like you're taking
note of what they have to say.
It's really critical
because, I mean,
we would like to
retain them as well.
So making sure that
their training experience
is going well even
though we've been
around to see an evolution.
Yeah.
Actually, I was thinking
about that with Posit
as well, because
when I started And.
We were 60 people, it's also--
like an onboarding experience
is going to be a lot different
than from when we have,
I don't know, 300 and
something or 400 people
and realizing that
people will have
different expectations depending
on that company size, too.
Libby, I think you had asked
a question a few minutes ago.
Do you want to jump in here?
Yeah.
And it was kind of along the
lines of what Amanda is talking about where people
come in and they have
expectations
that they've brought with them.
I have seen this happen
with a lot of people
and in a lot of organizations.
So I'm curious how
Dow handles it,
when you upskill a
bunch of employees
into better data skills
or a better data stack
or whatever it is,
and then they are not
able to actually use those
skills in their day-to-day job.
I've seen it sow a lot
of dissent in people.
They're like, OK, you want
me to learn all this stuff,
but you've given me nowhere
to apply all of this,
or I can't use that tool that
you taught me how to use,
whatever it is.
So how do you guys handle that?
Or is it not an issue for now?
Sorry, million-dollar question.
I'm letting Amanda go first.
I mean, I've definitely
seen it be an issue at Dow,
like when people go through
more generic outdoor service
training and then we
analyzed the environment,
so then they can't do
things exactly how they
learned in the training, so
that can be really frustrating.
And so we're still working
through combating that.
But I think as far as
getting-- like giving people
access to other tools,
I haven't seen so much.
Like people want to go
do a JMP training, cool,
then they'll have access to
JMP or [? SIMPER ?] [? ROW ?] or
whatever it is.
But I've definitely seen that.
And so from an Insight
Scientist Community perspective,
we definitely
raised those issues
to leadership that could
actually help us take action.
We got leadership to
help us talk to security
about the issues that were
preventing people from having
a similar experience.
I know Alix, James,
and I definitely
are on many calls in the past
about those kinds of things.
And so I think we still leverage
the insight scientist community
to help us through that, to
try to make it as easy as
possible for people to
deliver their work while also
still doing it in
a secure manner.
Yeah, I'm so glad
you brought that up.
That is another one
of the key things
that the Insight
Scientist Community
does, is serve as a collective
voice for the technical people
on the ground.
Because you have-- what you get
is you have senior leaders that
go talk to tech
company executives
and hear sales pitches and
whatever, and it's like,
this is so easy, it'll
accelerate your work.
And then they bring them
in and we do a training.
And then it's like, OK, I'm
committed to this training,
I see all the content, we're
working through it, it's good.
And then we get it in
the Dow environment
and with the Dow security
policies and work
processes and all that
stuff, and it's nothing
like it was in the training.
And then your
senior leaders don't
understand why they haven't
seen the acceleration that they
were told would happen.
And it's just a
matter of education.
It's not like we're saying
that security is wrong.
They need to do what
they need to do,
but everybody needs
to understand that
that's happening and that it's
not just the out-of-the-box
thing there.
And so we can serve
as a collective voice
for those shared
experiences around
because the community
steering team does
have access to the senior
leaders of each of the data
science groups
around the function.
So there is a-- we did build
an intentional communication
path to senior leadership from
the Insight Scientist Community
leadership.
One thing I will
say again to answer,
I guess, the specific
question is--
so from those experiences--
and we also have
a lot of training
we're doing for people who
are never going to be a data
scientist, but they
either generate data
or they might use data for
day-to-day decision-making
within their jobs or
whatever, everybody
needs some kind of data
literacy at this point.
And so we have those kinds
of training programs, too.
And we have to be even more
sensitive to that issue
probably because it's not
really in their job description.
So we're making them do these
trainings that are possibly
not something they think
of as their core role.
And then if they
don't use it, then we
can really get those
resentment feelings.
So what we've done
is just basically
really, really
customize the training
to Dow and to their role.
So we don't deliver the
training unless it's
got examples of literally,
this is what you do,
you make these kinds of
spreadsheets or whatever,
you need to do it in this way.
And so yeah, I think
the issue you point out
is definitely a real thing.
And I guess the gist of creating
the content for that role
is that if you can't
figure out how to do that,
then maybe you should
reconsider if that training is
needed for that role.
So yeah, that's the
approach that we've
taken with our general
literacy training.
Really helpful points.
Thank you so much for that.
Maybe in the final
minutes here to tie it
back to what we had
opened up with about some
of the conferences
and competitions,
I'm thinking about
people who have
asked how to do these as well.
How did you actually learn what
was needed for the conference
or what goes into planning
an event like that?
Yeah.
Luckily, because Dow is a huge
company, we do have people--
like we haven't used
them actually for this,
but there are people whose
entire job is planning events.
And so we have lots
of admin support.
So people who can fill
out a whole bunch of forms
for badge access, who
can do a lot of stuff.
So there's pretty
known things there
on how do you get a bunch of
people into one Dow location.
In terms of everything
else, I think
we've learned a lot
from the poster sessions
that we've done every
year since 2015.
So that helps us learn how to
gather technical submissions,
how to set up a
SharePoint to receive
abstracts and things like that.
We even this year--
people submitted their
proposal via a SharePoint list,
and then they added their
abstract and some extra
information once
they were accepted,
and then we used a
Power App to then make
the program for the sessions
available on mobile.
So we didn't have
to print programs.
We could be green and just do
electronic programs and things.
So yeah, we have our
Microsoft experts
using all the full
capabilities of NetSuite.
And yeah, the other key thing
is, you gotta schedule the day
around the executives.
So it's not easy to pick a
date, especially considering
it does have eight--
six to eight weeks
of lead up to it.
So you have to have a time when
folks can be working on that
and you don't have the August
month of vacation for Europe
and you don't have December off
for North America and that kind
of stuff.
But other than that,
you gotta schedule
it around the executives
mostly is what we've learned.
Yep.
Yeah, so definitely
start small--
ALIX SCHMIDT: --a year
to plan the whole thing.
So, I mean, it's--
AMANDA AHRENS: Yeah. --every
other year because
it's a lot.
A lot of work.
ALIX SCHMIDT: Yeah.
Yeah.
Definitely start small
and literally keep
every single document.
Like if you spent more than like
15 minutes crafting an email,
make sure you save that so that
it can be reused in the future
or at least referenced back to,
even if you're just starting
off with something smaller
like a poster session,
because then eventually--
I mean, we just naturally grew.
We're like, oh,
well what if we do a poster
session and some presentations
or a poster session and
the Data Science Challenge?
And then it turned into
a large conference.
And don't forget to have fun.
Like we wanted to-- we scheduled
in certain times for fun
and just hanging out and
catching up with people,
especially post-COVID.
I mean, that was
really important.
AMANDA AHRENS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
AMANDA AHRENS: We'll celebrate
with mimosas or drinks after.
ALIX SCHMIDT: Yeah.
AMANDA AHRENS: The
Organization Team--
Planning Team advice, yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: That's great.
Well, thank you both so much for
joining us here and answering
everybody's questions.
Thank you all for the
great questions, too.
I appreciate it.
And hope to see everybody
back next Thursday, too.